You know what to keep, what
concerns me is, uh, this,
the rise of people that think
that everyone owes them something.
Sure. You know, that's,
that's, that's the weird one.
Like we were talking about AOC who,
you know,
she seems like a nice girls cause looking
woman. She's young, she's got energy,
she wants to do good things.
She wants to do some good ones.
But I saw the one thing that said
give money to people who are unable or
unwilling to work. Yeah. That's the
saw that, and I'm like going to work.
Well it's not in, they pulled that
out. They pulled that part out.
The unwilling park in her unable to work
makes total sense. You know, we would,
as a community,
we should take care of the people.
Most of the people that are now in
comedy or unable to work, most of us,
most of us, yes. This is
the only thing we can do.
But her thing was a weird one because
that, that thing, unwilling to work.
It's like, hey, hey, hey. He just,
he just crossed over into
crazy town like this is,
but that means that crazy town was always
in the back. You always had that. Yeah.
When you put that on paper.
Yeah.
That means this is something
that's been discussed,
like part of the appeal and she just,
I don't know how influential she wasn't
getting Amazon to drop out in New York,
but I live in Queens, so
everyone is paranoid. Amazon
was coming. That was a Bagel.
I, no carbs, no good. But I was in a
Bagel shop. I gave up dairy two weeks ago,
turning it around, trying to get
around. I was in a Bagel shop.
It was paranoid about Amazon.
Amazon's gonna come,
we're all going to get priced
out of our little shoe box.
Is it we live in or the,
some of the people that own
those shoe boxes were like,
I'm a millionaire now because
Amazon's coming and the,
but here's the thing,
it's hard to have a rational discussion
about inequality right now because in a
place like New York City,
it's so expensive to live.
And the reason for that is that it's a
destination for like foreign capital.
So essentially a lot of the
buildings in New York City,
foreign people buy apartments,
they don't live in them.
They use it to like launder money and
they buy them not even under their real
name.
They buy them under the name of a Shell
Corp like an LLC and then they have like
these investments and it really
makes everything insanely expensive.
That's what's making everything.
That's what's making a lot of real
estate in New York City. Expensive.
What do you what like
what if you got to get us,
what percentage of like expensive
apartments are owned by, I'll tell you,
between 2008 and 2014 I
think 50% of apartments going
into contract were cause I
do a shell,
but I,
I used to be a double decker tour guide
in New York City and so I do a show,
like a funny comedy show where I take,
I sell tickets,
I put people on a tour bus and then
we'd go around to these buildings,
just scream at these buildings.
It's fun. It should be illegal,
but it's fun and,
and no one cares because they're not home.
Because there somewhere,
I mean if Hillary,
if you look at who owns these buildings
is a guy who like is maybe a guy who
owns a mining company and he
poisoned to river in Zambia.
The a lot of these guys who are doing
things they shouldn't be doing and they
want to stash their money in real estate.
London is insane.
It's more expensive than New York
because London is all essentially shell
corporations. You know these phantom
buyers buying up real estate in London,
in New York, so you have people in New
York that know the system is fucked.
They know the markets being
artificially manipulated.
Bloomberg thought it was great. Bloomberg
is, we want all the billionaires.
He said it. That was his
quote. We want all of the bay.
It's like some of those billionaires
have done things that would make you,
would keep you up at night.
They've numbers like bring them in.
They eat shrimp and steak.
They've got a Peter Luger's.
We love him as a businessman,
right? That's the thing.
So people get fed up with this and
dude, and when I was, had my tour bus,
people would get on from regular places
like Pennsylvania and I would just point
and go 10 million, 20 million, 30 million.
These people just shift
uncomfortably in their seats.
Like what the Hell's going on
here? This is the, you know,
I saw Trump getting elected during those
tours because I'm like $100 million and
they're like sitting there like, what?
I can't afford a knee operation. Well,
the idea that Trump's not a part
of that as he listen in his bit,
his building was a huge destination.
Russians love his building. They love it.
They love a brand name. They love
the plaza, they love his building.
And a lot of interesting
characters lived in Trump tower.
Didn't they take the Trump tower name
off of it in New York? Yeah. Wasn't, no,
it was one of the buildings where the,
the people that own the co op
decided to take the name off of it.
Maybe there's a lot of shitty like Trump
nursing homes to live in in New York.
Oh yes. Nursing homes. You know those
elderly people getting beaten. It's hard,
Joe, you know, they're getting
fleeced. The beaten. You go by,
you see like Trump pavilion.
It's like a Soviet era architecture.
Horrible like old age home that's been
there since the 70s and I'm like, man,
I feel for the people in there,
the screams of must other than New York
condo votes to remove Trump from name.
Yeah,
New York City condominium on Thursday,
we removed president Trump's
name from the buildings facade.
The second time at four months,
his name has been removed
from a condo in the city.
55% of Trump plays condo owners at
120 Riverside Boulevard in Manhattan.
Voted in favor of removing the large
sign above the front door. The buildings.
I mean that crazy. Who Cares? These are
self important people, but when care is,
they're worried about their secure.
Oh, that's a good point. Yeah.
I think if you try to sell it and it's
Trump place and you know you're going to
eliminate 50% of your buyers dictators
that are buying those apartments,
I think it's great. They die. Maybe they
don't. Maybe they're like, you know,
this is probably, we'll probably go down
the street to this no name building,
we'll be better off. But a lot of
his condos were sold to, you know,
Mafia and you know, the Russian business
guys, and he's always hide that,
you know,
he did deals.
It was his firm located in Trump tower
called Bay rock financial, which was a,
it was headed by this guy, Felix Sader.
Felix Sater was a guy that the FBI, uh,
convicted in like a Russian
pump and dump stock scam.
And he worked in Trump tower with Trump.
Like he worked very closely with
Trump and Felix had like informed,
I think on the Russian mob for the
feds and the feds kind of let him earn.
And so Trump has had this of
shady connections forever. Wow.
And I don't know if that
means that he's ness.
I don't think he's an asset or
of Putin or anything like that.
I don't believe that. I think that's
kind of just, you know, I think it's,
a lot of people would like to
believe that, but he's a shady guy.
So if you have all these people pouring
over his business deals for the last 50
years,
it can't be good.